I've had like, six, yeah, six cities now I've done concrete in
Florida. Okay. And all the DD the search volume checked out.
I mean, like, you know, when you search on SEM rush, you get like
the main number on the bottom left, you have related keywords.
I mean, add all those up. I mean, there were it was like
100 200 300 searches a month, right? So like, the search
volumes there, but it was getting no impressions after
like eight or nine days. So I just went ahead and pause those.
But um, and I took the number off a call rail, so I wasn't
paying for it. I don't know if that does anything for like
future payments anyway. Um, my question is, do you go back and
test those cities again? Maybe like two weeks down the road,
because maybe like the first time around for for whatever
reason, there was like a glitch in the algorithm or something
happened. And like the second time around, like it actually
performed really well for you. I don't make no sense for those
cities not to be getting zero impressions or two impressions,
three impressions, you know?
Yeah, I definitely will test them out. I'll circle back on
everything. I don't do it two weeks later, though, like I'll
wait a couple months. Okay, because I think it just my head,
I'm always like, I wonder if it has to do because I know, like
on paper, where, you know, you're really close to me. I'm
in, I'm in St. George in Vegas, we're basically like, it's 70
out there. And so I think, like, and I know what the weather is
like in Florida, but also, I, so I'm always like, let's, let's
like, wait till the next season and try it. So I'll pause and
unpause shit. Because, and that's the same way I and I do that.
Because when I used to sell door to door, there would be
neighborhoods that I would give up on, I'd go, I'd knock the
doors, and I had a bunch of freaking douchebags. I'm like,
oh, I screw this neighborhood, I'm never coming back. But then
like a couple months later, I'm like, now I'm going to go back
in there. And then I would get that first deal. And all of a
sudden, I would blow that neighborhood up. And I'm like,
okay, I'm glad I didn't give up on that. So I always serve you
guys, I did a training, like way back when my mood was in town,
on just working your areas. And that's the same for projects,
you guys have projects that like, you want to just pick and
shit on them and like get rid of them and burn into the ground.
Just relax, pause it, go get a deal. Get that momentum, come
back and work on it. And the same with ads, pause it, if you
get rid of your number, whatever, that's fine. And then
just come back, you know, a couple months down the road. So
I would definitely circle background, especially if like
the CPC lines up, and their search volume and the whole
deal, then I would just come back, I would definitely not
give up on that would come back. Because if not, you could shoot
them to me and I'll try them out.
Yeah, I'm definitely gonna try them out again. Because like I
said, everything is perfect. And these are cities that were like,
in between Central Florida to like Tampa. So if you're
familiar, you guys, so you got like Brandon Riverview, stuff
like that 100,000 population. I mean, and I have I have a
couple of sites, a few sites in Florida, like Gainesville,
Ocala, you know, Palm Coast, St. Augustine on the East Coast,
I have less population less search volume than those five
did. Yeah, and they were they were getting leads and
impressions left and right. Well, for those five or so, for
whatever reason, they just weren't getting any impressions.
Yeah, I don't know.
Think about it like this. Yeah, I have a site called Cedar City
concrete. I have a site Bentonville concrete, those are
30,000 population. And they're like they're getting 30 like
Cedar City is only getting probably like 10 to 20. But
Bentonville has been doing 30. There is concrete volume in
every city. I don't care where you're at. There's always going
to be some like at least 30,000 plus there's going to be concrete
volume. So yeah, if it's if you're talking 100,000
population, all the metrics are there. Come back and hit it
again. Okay.